al triángulo p w se le aplica la
traslación y estamos utilizando una t
mayúscula para denotar traslación donde
esta es la traslación que le vamos a
aplicar al triángulo vea w - 2 - 3 que
quiere decir que a todos los puntos del
triángulo p w en el eje de las x su
imagen de cada uno de los puntos va a
decrecer 2 unidades es decir vamos a
mover cada uno de sus puntos dos
unidades a la izquierda y en el eje de
las yes también va a decrecer tres
unidades vamos a mover cada uno de los
puntos en el eje de las tres unidades
hacia abajo ahora para hacer la
traslación me voy a enfocar en los
vértices del triángulo p w porque eso
facilita las cosas para mi cerebro pero
también la herramienta espera que
hagamos eso que nos enfoquemos en los
vértices del triángulo p w
primero hagámoslo para el punto a en el
eje de las x el punto a va a moverse dos
unidades a la izquierda es decir su
punto correspondiente
imagen de crecer a dos unidades en x
ahora su coordenada actual en x 5 así
que le vamos a quitar dos unidades me
quedara en x igual a 3 y su coordenada
actual en que es 8 como va a decrecer 3
unidades
entonces me quedara en ye igual a 5 por
lo tanto su punto correspondiente en la
imagen después de la traslación será
este 35 hagamos lo mismo para el punto p
el punto p tiene coordenada en x igual a
menos 1 si lo movemos dos unidades a la
izquierda
quedamos en x igual a menos 3 y en yale
punto p tiene coordenada 4 como va a
decrecer tres unidades quedarán ya igual
a 1 así que el punto correspondiente a
la imagen después de la traslación del
punto p será menos 3 1 aquí quedará la
imagen del punto p ahora hagámoslo para
el punto w la coordenada en x de w7 si
le quitamos dos unidades quedará en x 55
positivo
y su coordenada inglés iguala 1 si le
quitamos 3 unidades quedarán igual a
menos 2 así que la coordenada
correspondiente la imagen de w después
de hacer la transacción quedará en 5
como menos 2
y ahora conectamos esta es la imagen del
triángulo w después de aplicar la
traslación - 2 - 3 comprobamos correcta
hicimos la traslación